[Musica]
oggi vi racconterò un po lato diciamo
romantico no della mia nei miei ultimi
30 anni perché quelli sportivi poi sono
scritti sono facili da reperire mentre
ma magari quello che avviene dietro le
quinte è un po più un po più nascosto un
po più intimo la mia ai miei ultimi
trent'anni ma la mia vita in generale si
può probabilmente riassumere in cinque
punti
la scoperta è l'amore per il mare
mia madre
le persone e luna rossa sicuramente è
l'ossessione
l'ossessione nel
nel voler ottenere sempre di più
nell'essere
dipendente della sessione
che mi ha portato ad essere qui oggi e
probabilmente
mi porta a non essere ancora contento di
quello che ho fatto
io vengo da una città
particolare rimini no perché il mio
amico cevoli dice la città dei patacca
in patacca sono
rappresentano una serie di forme no la
curiosità la voglia di divertirsi la
superficialità
i miei genitori mia madre gestiva un
albergo avevamo un albergo da da tipico
riminese mio padre faceva un lavoro dove
era spesso fuori fuori italia
e io ero uno abbastanza irrequieto da
piccolo tant'è che il soprannome fino
alle stati pochi anni era prozac
e quindi il posto più più semplice e
sicuro dove lasciarmi era era la
spiaggia il mare da noi sono famosi i
bagnini
negli anni 70 c'era una piccola scuola
vela di fronte al nostro albergo
io ero affascinato da tutto ciò che era
un qualche cosa che galleggia nell'acqua
e c'era una piccola barchetti na della
proprietà della scuola che era ormai
abbandonata perché era una barca negli
anni 40 50 la piccola deriva un sunfish
e io giravo tutti i giorni attorno a
questa barca questa scuola vela con
un'ossessione tremenda su questo oggetto
il criterio della scuola ha preso dalla
disperazione un giorno mi disse va bene
tua se riesce a metterla in acqua puoi
usarla e andare per mare
ci misi poco meno di un giorno era
sotterrata per metà e non avevo la
minima la minima idea di come si facesse
andare per mare andar per barche eravamo
ero molto alla ventura
cerca di farla breve la cosa
la cosa che mi ha tra che mi ha attratto
di più dal mare al fatto che
il mare come la montagna no basta
vedersi oggi qua è una cartolina
virtuale in movimento che cambia in
continuazione
e andare in mare all'età di 67 anni da
solo
ti mette una condizione un po al di
fuori della tua con forza no perché sei
fuori se da solo
io dico sempre il mare mi parla perché
mi dà dei panorami dei paesaggi dei
colori diversi in ogni momento e ho
iniziato a farmi un po di domande e
questo mi ha portato a
a creare una curiosità che poi mi ha
portato a cercare di scoprire cose nuove
non è la ma nella mia dalla mia nel mio
cammino
che poi diventato il mio cammino
professionale ma altro aspetto
fondamentale è stata la perdite mia
madre io ho perso mia madre o poco più
di un ragazzino avevo 10 anni e mezzo
la madre per un bambino è un punto fermo
no è un po come questo
questo pezzo di roccia qua sai che li e
poi sempre fare affidamento
e per un bambino quando perde la madre
perde un attimo i riferimenti e aveva
due scelte o lasciarmi trasportare dagli
eventi
nel fare magari una brutta fine come
hanno fatto alcuni dei miei amici
oppure oppure rimboccarmi le maniche e
cercare di trovare dei nuovi stimoli e
trovare dei nuovi punti di riferimento e
sembrerà strano ma per me soprattutto
quando avevo 10 11 anni
la musica è stata una cosa fondamentale
mi ha aiutato tanto è stato il mio
il mio amico migliore perché alla fine
attraverso la musica
riesce a recepire emozionino
trovi attraverso un brano un artista
il migliore amico che vuoi quel momento
quello che ti sa dare la spinta per poi
andare avanti
e questo ha fatto si è ovviamente creato
in me un carattere abbastanza forte
estroverso difficile a volte perché
comunque sono sempre stato uno che ha
cercato di proteggersi
all'esterno
non volevo mai parlare non di quello che
mi era successo però mi ha reso molto
forte e mi ha insegnato a selezionare le
persone di cui volevo circondarmi
tant'è che ha appunto tipo e ha fatto la
differenza nella mia vita sono state le
persone che ho incontrato e sicuramente
nella mia carriera professionale
sono due persone fondamentali 1 a
livello professionale personale
che mia moglie mia moglie è stato il mio
prosa che è stata la mia medicina che mi
ha
aiutato
a bilanciare mi ad emozionarmi mi ha
fatto tirare fuori il meglio di me
perché credo che attraverso le emozioni
alla fine noi siamo in grado di
esprimere il meglio di noi stessi
mi ha insegnato
il rispetto delle persone
a dare fiducia alle persone
io mi sono trovato per tanti anni
dall'altra parte della scrivania ad
essere gestito ho iniziato la mia
gavetta facendo il prodiere quelli
passando dalla prua e piano piano
passando indietro ho avuto un rapporto
molto bellico con kimi gestiva nelle
prime campagne di coppa america e poi di
punto in bianco incontrato una persona
che patrizio bertelli che ha avuto la
follia di darmi la gestione di un team
io da da un giorno all'altro son passato
dall essere gestita dover gestire un
gruppo di lavoro di più di 120 persone
e più di 200 collaboratori esterni
e questo perché sono state fondamentali
queste due persone perché uno mi ha
insegnato
l'emozione e nel trasmettere l'emozione
e nel fare emozione emozionare le
persone che poi lavorano con me o per me
l'altro mi ha insegnato dal fiducia alle
persone perché alla fine chi fa la
differenza non sono le cose materiali
non sono la tecnologia ma siete voi
siamo noi non siamo noi che siamo ancora
in grado di emozionarci davanti al
tramonto davanti a un paesaggio
ed è per questo che siamo poi alla fine
noi in controllo di quello che ci
circonda tutta la tecnologia alla fine
un asset per cercare di renderci più
felici
l'altro aspetto fondamentale ovviamente
la mia vita e luna rossa luna rossa fa
parte di me per più di vent'anni era
famiglia che è cresciuta
in maniera esponenziale
noi la prima sfida io ero quasi un
ragazzino disposto a spazzare il
piazzale pur di far parte di questo team
di questo gruppo perché al mio sogno fin
da bambino da bambino all'epoca noi
sognavamo diventare o piloti austronauti
o grisù
io sognavo di fare il velista
e sono riuscito a realizzare un sogno
perché alla fine io vivo di questo da
tantissimi anni
e siccome sono uno che crede tanto nei
sogni e crede dando le persone
ho lavorato tanto su di me e ho imparato
dagli errori sono stati fatti magari da
quelli che sono venuti prima di me nel
dare fiducia alle persone nel far
crescere i giovani perché alla fine i
giovani rappresentano il dopo il domani
il futuro noi siamo degli asset man mano
che invecchiamo siamo dei libri aperti
per chi perché ne ha bisogno e luna
rossa è stata un'evoluzione nella mia
vita perché ho iniziato da ragazzino ho
ho visto nascere tante famiglie la mia
famiglia è cresciuta all'interno luna
rossa i miei figli sono nati durante le
campagne di coppa america in giro per il
mondo
nell'ultima coppa america avevo in barca
due persone due ragazzi che erano figli
di velisti che hanno fatto la prima
coppa america con me quindi è veramente
una famiglia che si sposta un po come a
dei gipsy in giro per il mondo che
condivide
delle emozioni importanti
che non è solo il raggiungimento di un
obiettivo sportivo che ovviamente il
culmine di tanto lavoro di tante persone
ma è anche creare una famiglia
che aiuta poi a raggiungere l'obiettivo
l'obiettivo sportivo dico sempre che
quando facci colloqui con i nuovi team
member con i progettisti nuovi velisti
una parte fondamentale del risultato
finale di una sfida e la famiglia
sembrerà strano ma una famiglia felice
rende un lavoratore molto più
performante
e come dicevo prima l'ossessione per me
è stata una
un elemento chiave della mia vita
l'ossessione è la dipendenza dalla coppa
america e da raggiungere l'obiettivo
successivo io sono uno che non si è mai
seduto accontentato ogni volta che
vinceva un trofeo anche ultimamente
abbiamo vinto la prada capo no che per
magari per tanti poteva essere già un
obiettivo importantissimo
appena abbiamo tagliato il traguardo io
ho iniziato a pensare a come fare per
cercare di vincere la coppa america e
questo mi ha permesso di crescere sempre
di più ea non sedermi purtroppo dello
sport contano solo i risultati
oggi conta tanto
contano tanto i soci alle pubbliche
relazioni ma alla fine per uno sportivo
con richemont e cercare di vincere
quando uno non vince in qualche modo
fallisce quindi per questo diventa una
dipendenza un'ossessione cercare di
raggiungere l'obiettivo per cui tu
lavori tanti anni e per cui tu sogni di
raggiungere ho avuto la fortuna di fare
7 campagne coppa america e l'ho vinta
due volte ho vinto
tonnellate di regate di mondiali
campionati europei
però il mio obiettivo è vincere la coppa
america per l'italia e fino a quando non
riuscirò a raggiungere questo obiettivo
sarà ossessionato da questo le persone
le persone sono importanti perché alla
fine
io quello che dico sempre che non
facciate in meeting con le mie e con i
miei ragazzi con cespiti il bruni che
sono delle rockstar della vela la
rockstar e il team siamo tutti noi
insieme è un puzzle che viene messo
insieme se tutte le pedine non
corrispondono e non formano una
fotografia completa abbiamo perso tutti
insieme e per questo chiudo con una cosa
che va un po al di fuori della mia vita
è fondamentale che ognuno di noi
responsabile di quello che facciamo
delle nostre azioni ed è fondamentale
che ognuno di noi cerca di salvaguardare
il nostro ambiente il nostro mondo
il mondo in cui viviamo non pensiamo a
quello che faranno l'industria cerchiamo
di cambiare le nostre abitudini per
migliorare e per avere un futuro
migliore
grazie
[Applauso]